ready I got my lines all set all ready
and action
ring ring ring ring line you're fired
why Rachel Yankovic yeah and because
June was a because the ceiling with the
sword hole in that ceiling rod we don't
want that there's no holes up there at
all okay and be careful with that bad I
saw what you did to Doug with it last
time keep the staff out of his beard I
told you to take his stop see most
painful lines at a circumcision cut
scenes coke party that would make sense
okay drive guys ready
didn't you have the thing turned upside
down before doesn't matter okay
actually yeah turn around hey it looks
very listen to your daddy Rory to you
sacrificing heard less painful lines at
a circumcision cutscenes I got that one
less painful cutscenes of the
circumcision seem to know what's up
being a wizard was easy and action yeah
little more Ethel Merman this time I
think in the air and I just don't care
[Music]
The Dark Knight Rises indeed mind if I
talk to you monster okay yep at Chalmers
okay so that's what you guys saying
chinchilla chinchilla chinchilla
chinchilla re Apollo's as lucky as lucky
can be okay
hey guys really
and ready and action oh oh you'll never
be straight damn straight